I've a very simple aesthetic and I say
it all the time and I'm happy to share
it with you it's really clear to me
which is your obligation is to the story
as a whole that's all that's it
different parts can change you can be
working a different desk or decide
you're interested in different themes or
ideas or you're going to work a
different way you know your process can
change all throughout your life and you
know I assume does mine keeps changing
but the ideas that's the one thing that
stays steady for me that's what makes it
doable you just have to have some it's
it's a pretty existential life you know
I used to work all night and sleep all
day you don't have to have a day or a
night or you know it's it's completely I
was going to say about the word but it's
a it's it's not a standard lifestyle
you're building you know much like a
story gets built from negative space
you're sort of building routine from
infinity framing as I said day or night
I guess you have to believe in process I
think even writers get romantic about
process and they talk about it is
epiphany or you know i'm sure i've
already said it today but this idea that
you can suddenly have the final draft a
process has to have parts to it and that
idea you can't you simply couldn't sit
down it's a draft you couldn't sit down
and write the finished book that's not
how it works you're building a universe
like I think all those things is not to
see them as wrong turns that's what's
built into it is writing down one
direction writing down the other the
idea is having like the honesty or the
bravery or the ability to step away from
your own work and look back at it from a
distance and recognize what the story
needs if you're always looking to what
the story needs then then you'll
hopefully take it down the right route
and part of it I think that's what you
know keeps me interested I mean why what
keeps me driven what makes me want to
write all the time I think is that at
every stage every book every story each
one feels like me starting like now I'm
ready to work that's what I always feel
like and I think you don't even have to
know that's also part of it in the new
book the story sister Hills which is set
in the sort of the whole history of the
West Bank done in one story you know
compressed but I literally I remember
sending off to friends to a couple of
readers I'd written you know ten pages
15 pages and I literally I didn't want
the process you know affected in any way
I didn't want to know if it was good or
bad or if they liked it I simply was in
so deep and so did not know
what I had I'd simply send it to a
couple of people and said I want no
comments just tell me if these are words
are linked in order like does this make
any sense when you look at this are
there words on this page and doesn't
make any sense to you as a narrative in
any way at all I just want to know if
this seems part of something that is
comprehensible and they were like looks
like a story to me that to me it was
just so emotional and so loaded and so
you know the story where I most did not
know what I was working on or what I had
you know the night when I did not sleep
the night that I finished it I simply
did not know what I had and I think
sometimes following a story it's you
know it's a different part of the brain
the me that's talking to you this is
writer guy me the part of the brain and
we can talk about that that's engaged
when you're writing is wholly separate
from the person that you see